can you tell me whether the number you
see on the screen is a perfect square or
not
let me help you
we can write 5184 in the prime
factorization form like this
2 raised to 6 multiplied by 3 raised to
4. if the powers of all prime factors
are even then it is a perfect square
here you can observe that both 6 and 4
are even
that means 5 1 8 4 is a perfect square
let us take the next number which is 720
the prime factorization of this is 2
raised to 4 multiplied by 3 squared
multiplied by 5. here you can see that
the power of 5 is 1 which is odd so this
is not a perfect square using the same
concept can you tell me if 7056 is a
perfect square or not tell me the answer
in the comment section and don't forget
to share this video with your friends